hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren minecraft video ja
hague
ich bekomme wir befinden uns in der
minecraft version 1.9 wie das auch schon
so schön eingeblendet stets und ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich warum
steht im titel minecraft 2.0 dafür gehe
ich erst mal ganz kurz in den
singleplayer und kreiere mir hier eine
tolle neue welt die ich wie folgt die
welt wird hier gerade kreiert und
natürlich was ich gerade schon
angesprochen habe viele fragen sich
wieso bin ich überhaupt gerade in der
1.9 schild ist das denn im titel steht
minecraft 2.0 weil ich mal wieder auf
youtube unterwegs waren minecraft 1.9 da
gesucht habe und das hat sich alles so
aus jeder youtuber hat irgendwie ein
video zur minecraft 1.9 gemacht weil sie
ja frisch raus ist und weil es das erste
richtige minecraft update seit gefühlt
jahren war und ich hab mir früher immer
selber videos gemacht wo ich mir die
ganzen updates zugezogen habe und habe
dann gesagt ja das ist neu und dat is
cool hier meine kleine anwendung aus
einem höheren video heute ich stelle
euch hat den brandneuen minecraft
snapshot 12 10 03 ich weiß meine stimme
war da ein wenig anders
jetzt habe ich mir gedacht natürlich
könnte ich mit zu der 1.9 alle infos
irgendwie ein staat suchen und innerhalb
von vier stunden video aufbauen und euch
genau sagen was neu ist allerdings lade
ich ja selber in den letzten wochen
immer nur einmal pro woche minecraft
hoch und das würde dann keinen großen
sinn ergeben weil ich die mich selber
überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig
auskennen in dem spiel deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich stelle euch nicht die
1.9 vor weil es dazu wirklich millionen
videos gibt sondern ich zeige euch im
gegensatz zu den ganzen anderen youtuber
nie das wieso habe ich mir gerade eine
schaufel geholt wenn ich eben creative
not been im gegensatz zu allen anderen
youtube die ihr schon gesagt haben wie
dieses ganze die ganzen neuerungen aus
sehen uns diese habe ich denn jetzt
grade herz bekommt game mode 0 wenn ich
jetzt den hasen getötet
denn ich schaffe wenn ihr wissen wollt
was in der 1.9 alles neu dazugekommen
ist empfehle ich euch einfach einen
minecraft 1.9 neuerungen bei youtube ein
zu geben da kriegt die vier tolle videos
viele youtuber die das super gut erklärt
haben ich möchte euch allerdings wie es
im titel schon steht minecraft 2.0
möchte euch sagen was mich von minecraft
wieder überzeugen könnte sage ich mal
tröste mich jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen ausgehenden game ott 0 und
werde jetzt einfach mal sind die schon
immer so früh explodiert ich möchte
einfach so ein bisschen in diesem video
nicht sagen was 1.9 dazu gekommen ist
obwohl ich die einfuhren gerade spiele
sondern viel mehr sagen was mich von
minecraft wieder überzeugen könnte und
was ich für die 2.0 version einfach so
ein bisschen wünsche ich weiß es dauert
wahrscheinlich noch einen ja in etwa wie
ein pfeil
wieso ist denn der helm von wem kommt er
überhaupt avantgarde herzen warum mein
gott ich habe ein herzen lagen
herzlich willkommen auf meinem kanal um
jetzt endlich mal aufs thema zu kommen
ich finde dass in der minecraft 2.0 wenn
sie rauskommen würde was ich mir für die
version wünschen würde wäre einfach wenn
es ein ganzes minecraft eine ganze
minecraft alphaversion einfach nochmal
pre release gäbe ich schweife jetzt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen vom thema ab
aber ich beziehe ich jetzt gerne mal auf
andere spiele und zwar meine
lieblingsspiele waren bisher
für meinen alten gameboy advance das war
denn nicht mal licht hatte
dem habe ich pokémon feuerrot sehr gerne
gespielt das war mein lieblingsspiel und
super mario bros oder irgendwie so das
war jetzt nicht so wie dieses super
smash bros auf der wii oder sondern das
war wirklich das was man nur mario
zocken konnte der 2d landschaft über
hindernisse springen musste und so das
waren wirklich damals meine lieblings
spiele für die konsole die ich hatte und
dann habe ich mir irgendwann halt eine
playstation 2 hatte ich glaube ich mal
ausgeliehen gehabt von meinem onkel und
habe darauf dann sowas gezockt wie eines
der ersten gran turismo oder auch
beispielsweise gta san andreas oder
solche spiele und es war alles ultra
geil und dann kam irgendwann auch noch
modern warfare 2 raus was meiner meinung
nach immer noch das beste call of duty
aller zeiten war die maps waren hammer
die waffen waren hammer das ganze war
einfach richtig cool cod4 war natürlich
auch das war glaube ich modern warfare 1
da wo die oder ich weiß gar nicht auf
jeden fall gab es ein echt geile teile
und das war als meine lieblingsspiele so
das erste grand alles der ersten gran
turismo dann gta san andreas auf jeden
fall die an super mario und pokémon
sachen damals und ich finde seitdem ist
es mit jedem spiel bergab gegangen
pokémon haben sich die entwickler
gedacht ja wir brauchen neue pokémon und
haben sich mittlerweile über 5
milliarden pokémon ausgedacht und es ist
einfach unnötig weil ich nur die alten
pokemon einfach gefeiert habe so diese
version mit blu ray und pikachu und
diese ganzen neuen ich weiß nicht
weshalb den namen nicht mehr aussprechen
bei call of duty muss ich glaube ich
nicht viel sagen das hat jeder von euch
denke ich schon mal gezockt und
mittlerweile ist ja so dass jedes spiel
sich denkt und wie gehen mehr future
mäßig shit vor
zum glück minecraft noch nicht so
richtig bei gran turismo kann ich jetzt
nicht wirklich viel zu sagen weil ich
selber nicht so viele rennspiele zocke
aber meiner meinung nach auch bei mario
und so ist alles nur viel komplizierter
und so geworden ich bin selber ein
mensch
muss ich sagen eher simple sachen mehr
schätzt als sehr komplizierte sache dass
sie beispielsweise in allen sachen an
einem kanal beispielsweise main kanal
design da steht einfach nicht oben drin
wie bei anderen deutschen gamer jo ich
mache das projekt und da ganz viele 3d
animierte figuren und alles mögliche
sondern wirklich einfach nur schwarze
schrift auf weiß hallo mein name ist
luca mein profil bild ist ein komplett
bescheuert dass miley und meine ganze
merchandise shop et cetera seht ihr
selber hier einfach nur dieser smiley da
drauf ich mag linie sachen und ich
mochte mannschaft damals als es wirklich
pur minecraft war aber in den letzten
versionen ist für mich selber als
totalen tvp nur und jemanden der
wirklich überhaupt nicht zockt sondern
zocken eigentlich nur für youtube weil
es mir spaß macht das ganze dann
irgendwie als video zu bearbeiten ich
weiß nicht ob ich da gerade als einziger
darsteller aber ich würde mir für die
neue minecraft version 2.0 irgendwie
wünschen von jungs gibt kann es ja auch
zwei versionen geben eine mit ganz
vielen tollen sachen ich meine dieses
update 1.9 ist natürlich geprägt durch
die ganzen
combat sachen man kann jetzt ein schild
tragen jetzt gibt ein paar neue mops und
es gibt viele neue sachen das pvp angeht
das juckt mich aber alles ehrlich gesagt
rein gar nicht weil ich mich mit pvp
nicht auseinandersetzen wenn ich die
zeit hätte könnte ich locker auch gut
seine pvp ich meine das beansprucht jack
einen skill oder irgendwas sondern man
muss ja einfach nur zeit darin
investieren und dann kann jeder gut sein
ein paar schicken den späteren dem
moment erreicht wo ich nicht mehr
sprinten kann weil ich was zu essen
benötige allerdings sind weit und breit
keine tiere oder äpfel waschen hase um
auf den punkt zu kommen ich würde mir
wünschen dass einfach noch etwas zeit
der neuen version sind ja total kritisch
geworden was hier irgendwie bleibt ein
cello leibblatt doch hier rät bei der
wir würden einfach wünschen dass es bald
sonnen remake vom alten minecraft gibt
das wünsche ich mir auch schon immer bei
cod die leute begreifen ist aber nur
nicht ich würde voll gerne einfach cod
modern warfare 2 für die neue konsole
playstation 4 rausgebracht dass
währenddessen meistverkaufte cod weil
jeder dieses spiel feier und ich fände
es bei minecraft auch natürlich ist bei
minecraft was komplett anderes man muss
sich nicht immer neue spiele kaufen und
das ganze ist ein kostenloses update und
so deswegen ist es eigentlich dumm dass
ich mich beschweren weil ich es mir
nicht unter laden muss sondern auch auf
der alten version zocken kann aber
irgendwann hat die haben die alten
versionen zum beispiel mit seiner
minecraft alpha oder beta version kann
ich natürlich nicht mehr auf servern
zocken außer ich würde mir selber einen
server kreieren was total umständlich
ist übernimmt radio & hutch oder was ist
da alles gibt was ich mir aber irgendwie
wünschen würde wäre einfach ein remake
von der minecraft alpha minecraft beta
einfach nur wo der wert darauf lege
alles die grafik ist noch beschissener
und ich weiß nich hat eine flasche die
minecraft einfach der minecraft beta
gezockt ich habe damals mal so ein
projekt gehabt wo ich immer eine welt wo
ich immer eine folge hochladen habt die
dann weiß ich ich habe da immer eine
folge hochgeladen beispielsweise in der
minecraft beta 1.0 und dann habe ich
darf 50 minuten gezockt und dann eine
folge später waren wir in der minecraft
beta 1.1 und dann noch eine folge später
weil man minecraft beta 1 und 3 und dann
so sind wir quasi mal höher gegangen ich
habe das ganze nicht vollendet ich habe
nicht viele partys davon gemacht hat
fünf oder sechs oder so um den dreh weil
das ganze ein bisschen anstrengend wurde
mit dem immer upgraden und die ganzen
sachen wurden nicht mehr kompatibel über
welt zu welt upgrade allerdings war das
ultraleicht weil man damit so nostalgie
mäßig zurückgeschickt wurde in die alte
minecraft feld und das ist so meinen
aufruf allerdings ein bisschen ist wer
ultra nice wenn es möglich wäre eine
alte version noch mal zur remake mit ein
paar anderen sachen zum beispiel dass
man dann schon sprinten dass ich mir
einfach selbst aussuchen könnte was in
einer version dazu kommen soll oder
nicht natürlich kann ich dann nicht so
richtig mit der version auf servern
spielen weil man kann nicht zwei leute
auf dem server packen die mit der
minecraft 1.9 zocken und der minecraft
beta 1.0 aber das sind einfach ich
möchte einfach mal meine gedanken mit
euch teilen ich finde das so viel falsch
läuft in der spielebranche so viele
spiele sind natürlich geil und far cry
fand ich super und fallout das neue war
auch nice und gta 5 ist auch hammer und
natürlich spiele ich auch fifa jedes
jahr allerdings wünsche ich mir manchmal
einfach dass diese alte zeit zurück ist
mittlerweile konsolen wie die xbox wann
sie mittlerweile nur noch entertainment
konsolen wo gaming sondern kleinen
bestandteil einem ich weiß auch damals
der game boy advance sp mann macht das
ding auf wenn man es direkt im game drin
mittlerweile wenn ich den 3ds meiner
schwester nehme oder so bin ich erst mal
in so einem entertainment menü kann mir
auch film und alles anschauen das ist
natürlich schön und gut aber ich will
ich will back to the roots mann ich habe
keine ahnung ob mich irgendjemand hier
versteht und wahrscheinlich noch voll
viel rum von wegen steht minecraft titel
das forum war es ist kein 2.0 was soll
einfach mal meine gedanken so ein
bisschen teilen
derzeit findet dass einiges in die
falsche richtung läuft natürlich ist das
neue minecraft update hier cool und es
gibt wahrscheinlich echt viele coole
sachen wie beispielsweise dass ich
einfach ein schild in der hand halten
kann oder ich kann ja auch eine
spitzhacke beispielsweise in der rechten
hand tragen
aber was bringt eine spitzhacke in der
rechten hand man kann sich bestimmt
alles irgendwie erklären und es macht
alles irgendwie sinn und ich denke auch
dass 99 prozent von euch mit dem neuen
update zufrieden sind ich meine ich
finds selber neues sind bestimmt tolle
sachen dazu gekommen allerdings bin ich
ein typ der gerne die sachen so wieder
hätte wie sie früher mal waren und ich
weiß nicht ob ich mit 20 jahren
überhaupt schon dem alter bin so was
sagen zu dürfen und mich beschweren zu
dürfen über die neue zeit ich meine das
macht man ja sonst wenn man so ab 30 40
in der midlife-crisis früher war alles
besser
da war noch alles besser wiesberger noch
ein euro allerdings wünsche ich mir dass
ein bisschen und das video sollte
einfach dazu da sein um meine gedanken
so ein bisschen zu bündeln
zusammenzufassen wieso ist lava auf
dieser höhe hier man vielleicht denkt er
ja genauso wie ich und ich kann zwei
spitz hat gelernt halten wo ist da der
sinn ich motiviere ich hier mit schreib
mir eure meinung in die kommentare
ich lese ich schon immer alle kommentare
ich antworte zwar doch ich antworte doch
eigentlich sogar recht häufig oder mich
wird an dieser stelle bei besonders
interessieren weil ich glaube dass ich
der einzige bin so fühle ich mich so ein
bisschen der sonne meinung vertritt aber
wirklich wenn ihr so denkt wie ich oder
wenn ihr nicht so denkt wie ich eine
bewertung ist euch selbst überlassen
aber kommentare wäre echt ultra nice ich
würde mir einfach für minecraft 2.0
wünschen dass das ganze bisschen back to
the roots mäßig ist und an dieser stelle
sage ich jetzt einfach